if you're a megaman fan you're probably
hoping for another collection of the
classic games and you just might get it
I'm Tony and this GameSpot news update
has quite the legacy according to the
Korean Games ratings board a Rockman
legacy collection - is due for
evaluation soon Rockman being the
original Japanese name for Megaman of
course the listing says the game quote
combines seven to ten of the rock band
series that have been released in the
past since the first Legacy Collection
contained the first six games this seven
to ten presumably refers to Megaman 7
through 10 not 7 to 10 separate titles
as for platforms the listing calls out
ps4 Xbox one and PC that's all we know
for now but don't forget to Like and
subscribe to be the first to know when
this collection gets officially
confirmed Mega Man Legacy Collection
released on ps4 Xbox one PC and 3ds
between fall 2015 and early 2016 so if a
second compilation is on the way
a 2017 release date doesn't sound too
crazy maybe we'll hear something at e3
but for more Capcom action right now you
can check out our breakdown of
everything you need to know about Marvel
vs. Capcom Infinite
[Music]